pas est terminée je suis pas le seul
d'ailleurs il ya un certain alexandre
debanne qui n'a pas été invité
il a fait une petite interview n'en
parle et puis après je crois qu'ils
parlent de vous mes parents bien voilà
le m6 de nicolas de tavernost n'a pas de
mémoire c'est dommage mais ça vous a
fait de la peine non ça ne fait pas de
la peine je trouve que c'est un signe
qui est cohérent avec l'époque dans
laquelle on vit où finalement on se
déplace sans aucune racine et c'est
dommage parce que du coup c'est
difficile d'avoir un cap et d'avoir un
avenir quand on sait pas d'où on vient
en tout cas quand on l'oubli voilà il
est comment
l'histoire c'est moi qui l'ait découvert
sur m6 où il avait une émission
régulière sur m6 mais je les engager sur
vidéo gag je tiens à dire c'est un
garçon formidable de faire beaucoup que
je vois toujours j'aime beaucoup avec ça
leur est présentée avec alex les sursis
jane fostin sur alexandre debanne alors
avant avant tout va bien j'ai bac on
regarde ce qu'il a dit sur sur vous d'un
éventuel je sais pas si vous allez le
meilleur os autant qu'il ya une seconde
est possible il s'est contenté d'être de
faire des trucs faciles ouais il sait
pas à mon avis vu le talent qu'il avait
en tout cas le oui la voix il a raté un
peu le truc quoi je pense qu'il s'est
laissé flotter sur ses lauriers alors
que s'il avait bossé un peu plus pour
aller vraiment vers qui il est avec sa
vraie passion et elle aurait fait un
carton hélas raté le coche pour moi par
rapport au talent qu'il a alors on sait
ce n'est fait on se laisse happer par
ses lauriers ont fait là il arrive et
nous faisiez de la merde en fait non non
non mais la véraison il a entièrement
raison et je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec lui effectivement mais j'ai jamais
eu d'ambition en télévision c'est le
seul truc c'est que comme ça fait 38 ans
que j'y suis donc faut se poser aussi
les bonnes questions envoyées en mer
et je veux dire je vais vous dire à
décharge de tout ce qu'on a dans une
guerre de télévision ont fait des choses
parfois et on n'a pas le choix aussi il
faut bien travailler
et on fait une émission qui cartonne du
coup on ne nous est pas parce qu obligé
de la prendre moi on avait imposé la
famille en or que j'avais adoré parce
qu'une vidéo gag cas l'amener là une
étape où le samedi après-midi cartonné
donc on me donne famille en or que je ne
voulais pas faire mais j'ai des
émissions valérie intérim et la
pollution alors
être tout à fait honnête moi j'arrivais
part avec etienne mougeotte j'avais une
relation particulière avec etienne
mougeotte soit enlevé à lui dire
c'était comme un père de télévision et
donc j'arrivais à lui dire
l'arrivée à lui dire tu sais si je ne
n'ai pas vraiment envie de la faire je
ne suis pas sûr que je serai très bonne
et ça ils pouvaient l'entendre parce que
moi oui mais faire la roue de la fortune
aujourd'hui matin j'ai encore une fois
le matin dix ans valérie bègue c'était
très très dur très dur c'était vraiment
la version lot loué aux loges et je
ferai des ddd dean clients en plastique
il voulait aussi dense et de la colle
civile matin
j'ai eu l'info média est ce qu'elle vous
intéresse je vous déteste de plus en
plus c'est à dire que vous détestez déjà
avant l'émission mais alors fans à
lisbonne que si vous m'y ont autorisé le
jeu je ne dirai rien alesi pas parce que
vous avez travaillé donc allez-y c'est
le salaire que vous proposez m6
[Rires]
allez va les ir alors là salaire que
vous proposez m6 les gens vont être
extrêmement surpris 1 millions d'euros
nets par mois à l'année en cdi plus de
80000 euros nets vous avez refusé a dit
non je ne réponds pas cette personne
donc est ce qu'un enfant est bonne je ne
réponds pas c'est passé jusqu'ici
je réponds pas s'il arrive pas mais
c'était un contrat global sans faux pas
des faut pas charrier non plus le bout
d'un moment tout le monde n'est pas qui
vous savez
nos footballeurs professionnels oui oui
oui alors un petit footballeur un tout
bon goût n'est quand même pas si mal at
embarrassé je suis pas embarrassée elle
je viendrai embarrassé mois et l'oseille
ça fait 3 maintenant donc je vous dis
c'est que
oui mon petit clément france pub sur
alexandre debanne intéressés au matin et
l'élection de ben ali c'est bien oui
c'est pas mal alors ça fait très
longtemps que la part envers la télé il
se trouve qu'il est en pourparlers avec
france 2 pour revenir après plusieurs
années d'absence pour animer une
émission d' aventure pour moi très bien
avec un solitaire ça sera une sorte de
pékin express humanitaire c'est bien ça
s'appelle le nom de code sea world
michonne sokoura commandes mission
et l'idée c'est d'aller au tour du monde
pour des associations du matin c'est
très bien et j'espère que ça va se faire
pressant il a plus de 50 ans et les
blancs oui alors des finances l'a dit
plus de 50 ans et blanc dehors
0 genre de format il faut toujours des
fibres rotenberg alex 22 banned tu vas
parler m'a dit
tu veux et alors vous nicolas être
oublier nicolas de tavernost en revanche
il a abondamment cité cyril à plusieurs
reprises qui est d'ailleurs dans le
dossier de presse et web et c'est normal
qu'ils aient de série ils n'habitent pas
castaldi parce que bon il prend pas
beaucoup de risques il en parle bien
rappelle le courage allez on est sympa
[Applaudissements]